with Joe Ryman of Kadim in meadows first
of all welcome to the show thank you so
you are a chess player yourself yes but
why is it that you steered your company
to come sponsor this particular event so
I'm very casual chess player not on your
level but what I like about the chess
club is I live here in the neighborhood
and I like that there's that it brings
in a lot of new diversity to the
neighborhood not just mean age diversity
cultural diversity a lot of smart people
in the neighborhood you know so I enjoy
that when I'm walking the dog or getting
a cup of coffee it's nice to to have
have this institution here in the
neighborhood and you're sponsoring this
event but i'm sure you're involved in
educational initiatives as well you what
do you see the benefits of chess for
kids and in schools in your sugar sure
and and I know you've written about this
so i know it's something near and dear
to you by it i like you i think that the
logic skills that young players grasp i
like the idea that chest teaches
students to think two three four or five
steps ahead it's not like poker pokers
about to bluff that's that's not real
life real life don't say that Jason
trouble right above it but in my
experience you know is limited as a
limited scale to bluff but if you need
you but in the real world you need to
know we're going to be three four or
five steps ahead and so I think that's
such a valuable skill to be able to
introduce young students we don't like
it's in trouble Jennifer so we're gonna
say it's a book okay okay all right so
you're a chess player i get i said that
i have you had a chance to play Rex yet
no i haven't had a chance to play Rex
but i did get the chance to play garry
kasparov in in an exhibit a few months
ago here at the chess club so probably
that was certainly my most exciting
moment you one of course of course
naturally let's go ring that we know
Garrett watch no Gary okay I think
Gary on on the show sit to rebut yes
yeah to talk about that yeah yeah as a
matter of fact no you did mention being
a resident did you ever think that chess
would be something that your city in the
central west and at your city of st.
Louis's so are in our business we we do
business in 35 different countries on
six different continents first of all
look at this crowd yeah I mean it's
incredible it's so incredible but so I
see chess everywhere i go i love it and
to have it right here in st. Louis and
have this crowd is just it's really
amazing you know really exciting well we
appreciate your yeah you're sponsoring
chess uh-huh your company showing that
that organizations and corporations can
see the benefits of chess definitely and
will put their money behind it thank you
very much for Joe Ryman CEO and
president of cadman meadows one of the
visionary corporation seeing the
benefits of chess in the United States